well it's been interesting to put it
politely I think the first week has
reminded us why so few Labour MPs for
Jeremy Corbyn could win he's not a
particularly compelling speaker he is
outside of the political mainstream
which we were all shown when he refused
to join in singing god save the queen
and simples at the Battle of Britain
memorial service uh but we also seen
something else here which is why I think
he will survive as Labour leader for
quite some time is he's got a massive
mandate from his supporters winning the
leadership with sixty percent of the
vote on the first round and a full
candidate field and he's also wants to
do politics differently in a way that I
think that could strike some kind of
cord I think you saw well at PMQs today
when rather than going to the kind of
classic confrontational approach he read
out questions from members of the public
now ultimately I don't mean that does
the job of holding the Prime Minister to
account but I think I think I think
voters could find it refreshing but in a
long time I'd homie I mean Jeremy Corbyn
its electoral disaster for labor
well it changes the dynamic of that
contest because it always been assumed
that label would campaign put in but i
think that is by now no means certain
you know someone familiar with his views
on the matter says that jeremy corbyn is
ninety percent and outer i think it or
actually also gives David Cameron
opportunity because we've labor now
split on the European question for the
first time I think Cameron can offer
some concessions he's probably going to
end up having to offer Tory MPs in the
end now and not be attacked by labor so
I think you can declare the Tory party
machinery will stay neutral during the
campaign and that one Sri negation is
over Tory ministers and MPs can have a
free vote and it's very hard to see how
labour could attack him for doing that
ivete dura skeptic Tory MPs think Boris
Johnson is moving their ways ah they
cite several things first of all Boris's
view that the City of London would do
just fine outside the EU that he's
expressed in various private meetings
secondly they're kind of private moral
support when he gave some of the people
who rebelled against the government to
defeated on the per the rules for the
referendum and finally it is but I think
becoming increasingly clear that our boy
shonta needs to do something different
if he's going to end up becoming Tory
leader if he's going to beat George
Osborne and back in the no campaign is
the obvious way to do that and it was
very striking a poll this week but among
people who voted Tory at the general
election already in more of them want to
leave than stay